all right completing the square can we
remember how to complete the square I'll
give you a step for free though
admittedly it's a very easy step I want
to take this thing and complete a square
out of it right so I want to get that
minus r you want to get it out of the
way okay so your first step would be
this let's put that three over here on
the right-hand side okay but now comes
the tricky estepa completing bit I want
to add something what do I want to add
okay so it's going it's going to come
from this number right it's going to
come from this number I want to know
what number would i add to this to make
this whole being i cut a perfect square
good morning okay i want to do two
things i'm going to have and then i'm
going to swear I'm going to harvard
square pocket square so you have that
and that gives you four and then you
square that four times four is sixteen
you add it to one side so you better add
it to the other ok so now on the left
hand side and wallah i have my perfect
square this is something or squared what
is it y plus form okay so these are the
kinds of things right where we need to
be able to recognize those a bit quicker
so that we're not wasting brain time
trying to think a little what's the
purpose where we can't always if you try
something if you try like y plus eight
squared that's a common error to meet
because you see it yet you think that
that would get better go but you can go
back and you won't get your original
line right so it's always easy to test
I've just got 19 over there cuz i'm
adding this together having made a
square what I doing this square why is
it useful I can take the square root
both sides right so that leaves me with
y plus four over here and on the right
hand side 19 is not a square no bar
right so it's going to become the square
root of 19 right what I'm missing one
plus or minus there's two there's two
different numbers that I can square to
give me 19 one of them is the positive
one and the other one is the negative
one okay last step I just hope y by
itself right so i will check that for
over the other side and oppose
okay so that was a fairly involved
process is a lot of thinking even though
there weren't many wines okay um this
question doesn't say anything else in
terms of you know how do you want the
arts are so that's exact you don't need
to do anything to that okay but if we
were asked to for instance approximate
that happens sometimes it will happen
increasingly as you'll see in the next
lesson so if i wanted to approximate
this i'm going to get this into my
calculator and I get a couple of
decimals out of it okay last one because
completing the square is you know a
mentally intense task to do we developed
this is like a last thing we did we
developed the formula write the
quadratic formula and it's this long
awkward fraction I'm going to actually
help you remember it so that once you
use this you just put all your numbers
in one two three and you don't need to
think about it almost you just have to
substitute so who can help you remember
the quadratic formula what's all this
whole minus nothing yeah minus B what's
in the middle plus minus plus or minus
which corresponds to this plus or minus
and then because it's square it coming
after here what's underneath the square
root these websites for B squared so
very close minus 4ac which is
interesting by the way we'll come to the
fact that sometimes that number can be
negative you're like what's that about I
don't know if you remember that we have
a look at it again that's the numerator
okay very good you're close what's the
denominator it's simpler to advance just
too many good okay excuse me so all that
matters here now that we have this
formula is automating the process right
so you've got your a here you've got
your be here and there is C don't forget
it's got that minus sign hanging onto
the ride okay so now we know what a B
and C up let's just throw it in okay my
mistake that's just going to be minus 3
Chuck that plus or minus in the middle B
squared I just dealt with this 0 3 a
square and nikes me 9-4 now here comes
my amrc right it will be 2 times
remember we talked about that negative
negative 4 ok two times negative 4 i'm
even going to write that run just
evaluating turn away okay and I'm then
going to divide by
for okay now we will just mention um you
guys know just as much as I did that 2 x
84 is just negative 8 okay and you
probably could do that in your head but
that's such a common place for errors to
come up that people accidentally you
know don't get the sign wrong here or
we'll get the number if i write both
numbers there and I make a mistake I can
find it later okay but every time I skip
working that makes it harder for me to
trace my own errors okay teachers make
arrows too so you make it easier for it
to find rather than huh okay we're
pretty much ready to go we've got that
minus 3 somebody's okay what's happening
there I've got nine double negative that
becomes a plus right plus 1 32 right 4
times 2 times 4 32 that for still
hanging around on the bottom okay 932
that's a bit of an awkward number that's
just 41 I'm guessing my brain still
works over the holidays and that's it
just like we had before it's a messy
shirt so you can't really do much to
simplify that unless they want to be
doing a lot to me okay